welcome back to new rock stars this is
big question the show that gives you too
much information about spiderman no way
home
a movie with a plot that fans know more
about than the actual actors do
my name is mt and i am here today with
the one
amazing one and only eric voss how you
doing today eric oh i'm doing great mt
spiderman no way home is coming this
december it's fans are speculating that
along with the return of alfred molina
as doc ock and jamie foxx as elektro
we're also getting cameos from tobey
maguire and andrew garfield
despite those actors denials so eric are
toby mcguire and andrew garfield going
to be in spiderman no way home
or not and if not why are so many people
convinced that they are going to be in
the movie
oh uh one of the the biggest questions
of the century honestly
well uh i should say andrew garfield has
denied it i don't know if tobey maguire
has denied it
uh other people have denied that tony
mcguire is in it i don't know if he
himself
toby's a slippery guy uh he's he's hard
to get your hands on that's
by design give me rent get out of the
way um
well i'm glad we're talking about this
though because this is a conversation we
don't really normally go into at new
rockstars because
we're not scoopers like we don't have
inside sources
and we generally avoid leaks or what
people say are leaks on places like
reddit or 4chan
mt and i are just film nerds we react to
the movies and the tv episodes the
trailers the interviews the widely
reported news when it comes out and then
we analyze
and we theorize from there and as you've
known our theories are often debunked
that's
that's like the fun of it right yes it's
literally
like it's it's the it's what's part of
being like a nerd scientist that's what
i call it it's like
you know we put out a hypothesis doesn't
work out it's okay then we just put up a
new one that's what makes it fun
that's what makes that fun um but really
this whole narrative that toby mcgregor
and andrew garfield are going to be
coming back and spider-man no way home
and a lot of people are saying that
daredevil charlie cox is going to appear
as well
and every villain that's been in every
spider-man movie ever
it's turned into such a speculation
frenzy where no one can be believed at
this point
and i think we've kind of lost sight of
reality we can't even talk about this
movie without addressing this question
so uh this episode mt and i are gonna
lay out the facts
we're gonna cut through the [ __ ]
we're gonna explain the timeline of how
we got here
and yeah uh that does include the role
new rockstars has played in this
narrative
our hands are not clean i would like all
of you to join us as we go down this
rabbit hole
of spider-man into the storm
but let's catch everyone up on the
background um it all really started with
sam raimi
the man the myth the legend uh he
directed
of course the tobin maguire spider-man
trilogy with kirsten dunst and james
franco
now a lot of people don't know this but
there were plans for a fourth
sam raimi film that was going to be in
2011 and it was going to feature
john malkovich's vulture and then cash
in on all these other seeds that raymie
planted for the lizard dr connors and
uh bruce campbell as mysterio bruce
campbell appears in all those movies in
different roles and then they
storyboarded out an open shot where he
was going to get arrested
uh because he's still like the failed
actor mysterio uh
quentin beck oh man i would have loved
to see if he would have killed it
it would have been great maybe one day
we'll get to actually see it um but
uh raymie graciously stepped aside and
he let sony move ahead with a reboot
from director mark webb that was going
to start andrew garfield as peter parker
and that leads us to the 2012 amazing
spider-man that featured reese eiffen
says lizard and emma stone as gwen stacy
uh and then there was a 2014 follow-up
with jamie foxx's electro
and dane dahan as harry osborne follow
the death of gwen stacy arc
it ended with a kind of tease for a
sinister six future
but mixed reactions one of the lessons
yeah i like how you said harry osborne
and not green goblin because
like whatever the hell that was it
wasn't green goblin not my goblin
not my goblet at all uh
so in 2015 uh
miracle sony inked a deal with marvel to
share spider-man and reboot him again
with tom holland in the mcu the one we
now live with and know and love
yes that's when happiness first entered
my heart oh it's been great
from that uh
[Music]
song and civil war that i'm doing a
terrible read
[Applause]
we've seen all the movies that we've
known the films directed by john watts
homecoming far from home the team at
movies infinity war and game
but despite the success i think most
people like tom holland there have been
fans who don't want to erase the legacy
of toby maguire andrew garfield
there's a lot they like about those
movies and when you know during this
time we've seen
like a star wars the force awakens bring
back all these old faces they just
bring those actors back uh actors that
we thought we'd never see again
and the hope has always been that marvel
could deliver that same kind of fan
service in some way
so that brings us to our second era of
the early speculation what i like to
call the fun
times of how these theories begin yes um
and it started in uh in july 2017 when
tom holland was promoting spider-man
homecoming and he told bbc radio one
that uh you know if uncle ben were ever
to come into the mcu
since you know as of now we have not met
the mcu version of uncle ben
tom holland said i kind of want some
maguire to play uncle
ben i think that would be super funny
but i don't think he'll do it ah
yes fan casting toby mcguire as the mcu
uncle ben
and a lot of people started buzzing
about that uh because yeah that'd be fun
it'd be fun for to
be so great to see that like when he
first said that i was like yo
that has to be the play because i would
love to see that call back
with great power comes great
responsibility
there are cars there mother get out of
the way
okay then jump ahead to december 2018.
this is when
spider-man into the spider-verse was
released and it introduced general
audiences to miles morales and the
multiverse and the idea
of different versions of spider-man all
appearing on screen together
and this movie specifically references
details from the raymie films that goes
on to win an oscar
so you can see people start brewing
these ideas of like can we see this in
live action can we see multiple
spiderman
in a room together oh yeah definitely
like you know the spider-verse did a
fantastic job with like breaking down
the concept of a multiverse
and like with and especially with with
those references to the rainy spider-man
films
people were just like oh okay so we got
little elements from here and little
elements from there but like they're
their own universe and like i can i'm
ready for this now i'm ready to see this
and then in july far from home premieres
but it does reintroduce jk simmons
who is in the rainy films with jonah
jameson and it's now j-john and jameson
in the mcu
and people's minds are blown because
we're like wait is he the same character
is he an alternate reality version of
the character
um sometime later simmons has asked
about it and he said that sony actually
wanted it to be a different version of
the character but he wanted it to be the
same
so they ended up compromising on this
version being bald without the hairpiece
[Laughter]
well some other things to remember about
far from home it ends with peter parker
in legal trouble and a lot of fans were
wondering if that meant matt murdock
could step in as his
defense attorney uh it also includes
weirdly a reference to bone saw mcgraw
macho man randy savage's character who
is unique to the first
uh raimi film that universe he was based
on crusher hogan from the comics but
bonsai mcgraw was a rainy character
and he gets mentioned on a poster and
far from home
so that just leads to more speculation
that we're going to get more rainy era
crossovers and cameos in these movies
so basically what you're saying that
this is this whole universe multiverse
is the mcgraw verse
yeah pretty much he's at the heart of it
yeah absolutely
uh everyone is made of slim jims slim
jim oh
yeah i want a one version of of mcgraw
in every uh
in every universe yeah and um kevin
feige even seems to tip his hat to this
he's always tipping that hat in
different directions but there's a big
one
at san diego comic-con later that month
where he said that the multiverse still
exists in the mcu despite
mysterio lying about it it still exists
and that's what led him to announce
doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness it was
going to come out in may 2021
uh and then a couple months later
spider-man 3 was locked in to come out
right after that
in july 2021 but then things got
confusing
as yeah it says these are confusing
times
wait which hulk do you mean you mean the
hulk randy
brawl these are confusing times brother
now you're crossing
oh that's different that's a different
hulk so we're talking about
uh remember august september 2019 that's
when
it seemed like spider-man was cancelled
from the mcu all of us lost our minds
yes because uh were broken yeah disney
and sony went
into renegotiation for how they were
gonna share spider-man
disney wanted to up their profit sharing
from five percent to 20 to 50
really they ended up settling for 25
while keeping i think 100
of the merchandise which is really where
all the money is made it's insane
it just allowed them to be able to sell
spider-man stuff in disneyland and
disney world which is
you know all about toys in disney world
that's all always about the toys in
general
that's yeah the gift shop you exit
through the gift shop let's leave
but the door is locked and the only way
out is through the
but they also agreed to share spider-man
for a third solo film which would end up
being no way home and then an additional
mcu team-up movie featuring spider-man
and feige uh uh got us all a little
excited by saying
in his statement quote spider-man also
happens to be the only hero
with the super power to cross cinematic
universes
so as sony continues to develop their
own spidey verse you never know what
surprises the future might hold
multiverse converts
[Laughter]
oh man that was a crazy day it was a big
day
um so jumping ahead uh things get a
little bit more confusing in january
2020 scott derrickson
gets removed as director from doctor
strange's multiverse of madness and then
replaced with
sam raimi of all people yes which
was a weird like like weird mixed
feeling type of thing because i love
scott derrickson's eyes strange one he's
like a fantastic uh director
but like raymie getting to direct the
doctor strange film you always wanted to
direct
i didn't see that i really do so it was
a weird like
dichotomy like mixed feeling type deal
first time everyone pointed out that
moment from
uh the second spider-man movie in 2004
where
jk simmons the first character to cross
over from the mirami verse said
doctor strange that's pretty good but
it's taken
so like people are like whoa he called
this shot a decade ago
people were saying is there going to be
is this like rainy directing both these
movies
is like what's really going to happen
here uh and then things got super
confusing
in january of 2020 uh where the morbius
trailer was released
and despite assumptions that this would
be taking place in kind of a separate
world the way venom and venom two
are uh at the end of that trailer the
mcu vulture
michael keaton adrian tombs shows up
says what's up doc
it confuses everyone
literally what no i feel like no one
really cared about morbius until
you show that shot and then now it's
like all right we have to see morbius to
see how this is gonna
tie into the mcu no one cared who i was
to like
tie into the mcu yeah on top of the fact
that there was graffiti of
a spider-man with murderer written over
it but it was the raimi-era spider-man
which was very odd and people were like
what is going on here what
is going spider-man when we're dealing
with obviously tom holland
dealing with the aftermath of the
spider-man far from home so it's just
like why would you do this like there's
a lot of really confusing things
happening at this point
and things got even more confusing in
february 11th of 2020 when
uh morbius set photos were showing uh
where is spiderman bus ad
that showed a daily bugle logo but it
was the rainy era
daily logo that's now in the venom 2
trailer
and then in light of this confusion new
rock stars looking for video ideas and
theories to speculate on we released a
video titled
spider-man new easter egg toby returning
and we put
a thumbnail with that bus ad and tom
holland uh spider-man and tobin requires
spider-man
i want to say about this video i offered
three theories for what this could mean
i didn't say that any one of those
things
would be true but to be honest with
everyone i want
toby to come back i want the toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man all these characters to be in
one shared spider-verse that's what i
want
yeah that's like the the most fun
version of this stuff
but as i've been proven with many of my
theories i
get debunked all the time i'm totally
ready to take the l on it
like it seems a bit of a reach but
here's a lesson that we have learned
here at new rockstars
is that a lot of people will really just
react to our thumbnails alone
and then spread that as news as news not
a theory
they don't see that distinction as well
as we try to make it uh actually
we looked into this according to our
analytics most commenters
do not watch more than 30 seconds of a
video before commenting
you probably commented on this video
that you're watching right now within
the first 30 seconds that's why people
always go first
first first first at the bottom like
it's so weird
and we've realized that the thing they
are reacting to is not
the opening 30 seconds of the video
they're reacting to the thumbnail
it's literally they see the thumbnail
and they're writing underneath the
picture
if only if the thumbnail can have its
own comment section that would be so
much better
right big lesson learned from this
nothing on youtube
write this down kids nothing on youtube
is more powerful
than spider-man in the thumbnail it's
true
you put spider-man in your thumbnail
your video that will set it up for
success
i don't know what it is but people
freaking go crazy over spider-man
it can even be i don't know a mukbang
just put on a spider-man mask
millions of views i don't even know what
i'm saying
[Music]
let's get back to the timeline here
we're now in march 2020 which we know
what happened here right
biden one super tuesday also uh there
was a thing called cover 19
and it caught shut down everything it
changed our lives forever right um wait
what was that what was that
wait i don't believe in that no what
kind of good vaccinated wow
um so what that means for uh film nerd
youtube is it basically shuts down
production and it delays
pretty much all the movies and tv
releases that outlets like us and many
other news
outlets planned to make content about
and had contracts with advertisers
to make content about had plans to go to
on tour to podcast festivals to talk
about
all that got cancelled and basically
youtube freaked out and revenue
plummeted
uh cpms which is how they calculate how
much ad revenue you make per
video just bottomed out um and what that
meant
is that creators like us and many others
got kind of desperate for scoops for
news
like we're like we don't have anything
to talk about anymore we used to have
like
pretty much daily content about a new
movie coming out or a new trailer coming
out a new casting news coming out
all that ground to a hole what am i
gonna do without my content
so the way new rockstar strategized
getting through this period was like
doing re-watches the past movies so we
did a re-watch in the infinity saga
we also watched the same rainy trilogy
we watched the andrew garfield
spider-man movies
we watched a couple dceu movies that we
hadn't done breakdowns for we started to
do the x-men movies
and we covered shows like rick and morty
and the boys you know we tried to
fill in the the time as much as we could
we barely got through it
uh but let's all admit it also led to a
higher than usual period of like
fan theories and speculation and false
reports because people are like whoa
whoa whoa evan peters gonna be in one
division let's make sure
we were jonesing bro we were just like
wait what you got if someone please just
tell us anything oh yeah
yep yep so during this time theories are
going nuts and in april 2020 uh
responding to rumors that spider-man 3
was going to feature matt murdock as
peter parker's lawyer charlie cox
actually
denied it uh he denied any involvement
at comicbook.com he said
i hadn't heard those rumors but it's
certainly not with my daredevil i'm not
involved in it if that's true it's not
with me it's with another actor
so then on april 24th sony delayed
spider-man 3's release from july 16th to
november 5th 2021 and it delayed it
again to december 17
2021 which is when it's coming out now
but that gave fans more time to
speculate and sony more time to just say
nothing about it right
yeah that's what they love to do it's
completely just like hey
we're just gonna push it back and then
just you know just let you guys talk
about it go crazy
it was getting a little chummy around
here so then other stuff in the nerd
world is happening that's a big deal may
2020
zack snyder confirms that the snyder cut
is happening it's going to release an
hbo max
which is a huge victory for everyone who
had been pushing to release the snyder
cut
and really it validated this whole idea
to speculate
over a film about the narrative behind
the scenes right like
deleted scenes alternate cuts when
studios might lie to you you know
because basically when the snyder cut
got released it confirmed all of it and
we're still hearing more headlines about
what like
joss whedon did behind the scenes like
this
that changed everything yeah yeah those
headlines bro
oh boy so then late in the summer uh new
rock stars we've been doing show like
this big question
and zach huddleston and i did an episode
called all spider-man movies connected
and live-action spider-verse
and it was really just zach and i going
through easter egg by easter egg and all
these movies that connects to each other
now we enter the next phase of this
process and i'm calling the scoop rush
scuba brush so it uh
kind of kicks off around august 19th
when
we got this covered claims to have a
source saying that tobin maguire is in
quote active talks to return as
spiderman for a cameo
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness now the intel that they quoted
is a source that they said was also
correct
about netflix developing an extraction
sequel so if they're right about that
they should be right about this right
well we have to do this a note on
scoopers
so what are scoopers how do they work
well um
an abbreviated version of this unlike
theory channels like new rockstars
scoopers claim to be reporters with
insider access and unlike us credibility
is
everything to them because they're
trying to be journalists they're trying
to present themselves as credible news
and they only really function
if their future predictions or their
reports
come off as being credible whereas we
try to just do theories
i say every time my theories are
probably going to be wrong just go with
me
um but uh since these folks are
unaffiliated with any legitimate news
outlet
they what they do is they'll make as
many claims as possible
so that if any one of these claims are
proven right they can claim
absolute credibility but they never
share their sources
instead what they'll do is they'll claim
that their source was right about one or
two things in the past
but they never point out how many times
that source was wrong which is more
often than not
a lot more than the times they were
right wrong wrong wrong or
whether any of those scoops were
actually obvious calls that
anyone could claim like i remember there
was one where like that guy said that
time travel was going to be an in game
and i look back and he's like my sources
tell me that
end game will feature time travel to
which i was like
like as soon as people were dusting in
that montage infinity war
i in the back of many nervous sets were
like oh they'll probably use time travel
to fix it right like
yeah it's like this is not gonna be a
permanent thing it's gonna it's like
it's just common
rationality that people had and like you
just run that as a story that that
doesn't make sense
and the troubling thing is that rather
than take the l
when they're wrong or when they're
called out here's what they'll do
they'll duck the question
and they'll just move on
to another juicy scoop they'll act like
they never said or they'll kind of
change their words or they'll do some
verbal gymnastics they'll be like well
what i actually said was this
uh and then um they'll just kind of play
the victim if people keep calling them
out they'll be like oh big media is
coming after me
uh social media censorship no not you
not you quiet quiet i'm getting
cancelled
and a recent example was one scooper
claimed
james gunn was going to cast zac efron
as adam warlock and guardians volume 3.
and the gun saw this it was like no
that's a bunch of [ __ ]
and he called him out on twitter and
that scooper refused to retract
even when the writer director of the
movie called them out publicly you are
fake news
bro that's just stubborn foolishness
what the heck james gunn has no patience
for
scoopers like that like he'll shut you
down immediately
and uh now that's not to say you
probably have are countering me right
now well this one scooper said this and
it was right for sure yeah there's a lot
of
folks out there who know when a trailer
is gonna drop because they know people
who work in media and they're like
oh well we have an advertising spot or
we know a youtube upload's gonna go up
so they can kind of say we think a
trailer is about to go up and then
they're right you know so like
not all of them are complete dirt bags i
know there's really great scoopers out
there
yeah some of them uh there's just
varying degrees of credibility
and as a rule it's not best to just view
them as your only source
a lot of those theories get confirmed it
seems on october 1st 2020 when
the hollywood reporter reports that
jamie foxx is returning to play
electro now on this report they don't
name who their sources and marvel gives
no comment
so why can we trust the hollywood
reporter and not some of the other
people who aren't naming their sources
well here's the hollywood reporter
because it's the hollywood reporter i
mean major industry trades like the
hollywood reporter deadline variety
entertainment weekly many others let's
put up our
our trusted sources board here these
folks have editorial
track records they are proven they have
relationships with people in the studios
and now
those relationships scoopers like to
claim makes these uh
outlets biased because like well they
don't want to offend the studio heads
but
really that relationship just kind of
stops these outlets from making up
[ __ ] because if they do
the studios will be less likely to grant
them access and exclusives in the future
which is why these scoopers don't get
access to these things most of the time
october 2nd the next day jamie foxx
posts on instagram but then quickly
deletes an
image showing three spider-man looking
at a rift in the sky with possibly a
lecture on the other sides
three spider-men all together what why
did he delete it
i'm telling you deleted posts is a big
reason why this is the thing right now
they're like why did you do it
why they do it why would you even post
it in the first place hmm
what's going on jamie so uh
then a couple days later uh october 4th
scooper daniel rickman daniel rpk he has
a patreon where he tells people a lot of
stuff
um and he's actually been one of the
better ones i think but he posts that um
sony wants to bring back dain dahan to
reprise his role as harry osborne
and then the next day rickman claims
that sony has reached out to kirsten
dunst to see if she has any interest in
returning
notice how he uses the words reached out
to see if in the interest so if it ends
up that kirsten dunst isn't in it
like well she reached out she didn't
respond to the email you know the
wording of this is important right
yeah so then october 8th 2020 the
hollywood reporter reports
benedict cumberbatch will be in
spider-man 3 as
doctor strange and you remember this
huge game changer because to many
this confirms that spider-man 3 would be
using the multiverse to explain how
jamie foxx lecture is back
and would connect with raymie's universe
now that uh
raymie is directing doctor strange ii in
the mcu
it all started to line up for us oh yeah
it's all coming together like why else
would doctor strange be in this movie
other than to shepherd in the concepts
of the multiverse exactly
big deal and then um the same day new
rockstars had already made
a video about this but like um now that
we had
this like coming out in the can we
released a rogue theory episode called
spider-man 3 spider-verse confirmed
tobin mcguire and miles morales
crossover
and we had you can look at this
thumbnail it has miles morales that's
caleb
mclaughlin from stranger things cat
spells for alice
with toby andrew and tom in there um so
it's rogue theory
but people see this thumbnail again and
they're gonna take it every which way
and that's just something we've learned
during this process then on october 12th
scooper andy signor claims that
he can confirm toby and andrew will be
in spider-man 3 and he cites an unnamed
source at sony
uh and then on october 15th sony
representative tells e.t canada
regarding toby and andrew rumors saying
quote those rumored castings are not
confirmed but it did not matter because
at this point the toad mcgregor and
andrew garfield rumor is now
irrefutable yeah it's uh i like how they
said they're not confirmed
which is like very interesting right um
people see that they're like
well that doesn't mean anything but
before we continue with what happens
next with this whole
theory uprising we want to thank some
people help make this episode starting
with our friends at mint mobile so when
it comes to big wireless providers
there's always a catch right the cool
thing about mint mobile is that there is
no catch
mint mobile secret sauce is that they
are the first company to sell wireless
service online only by cutting out
retail stores there's no crazy overhead
costs that get passed down to you in the
form of mystery fees
instead mint just passes on sweet
savings directly to you
here at new rock stars philip switched
to mint mobile he kept his phone and
number and he gets great service
he's paying a fraction of what he was
paying before switching for people
looking for extra savings mint mobile
offers premium wireless for just 15
bucks a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with their 7 day
money back guarantee
to get your wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and to get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mittmobile.com
bigq that's mintmobile.com bigqueue cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at memobile.com
big q we also thank our friends and
honey for sponsoring this episode we've
all seen that promo code field taunt us
at checkout while we're shopping online
you know like
yeah do you know the secret code do you
know it no that's like you can get a
discount come on
where's the code gives us that savings
fomo well thanks to honey
manny willy's searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart
and when you check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply
coupons you wait a few seconds you hit
the honey button
you wait a few seconds as honey searches
for coupons it can find for that site
and if honey finds a working coupon
you'll watch the prices drop
here at new rockstars off-screen
producer zach is a huge honey fan it got
him free shipping on an order
from target.com recently honey has found
it's over 17 million members over two
billion dollars in savings and if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing on free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this show
we'd never recommend something we don't
use get honey for free at join honey.com
bigquestion that's joinhoney.com big
question okay now back to this whole
spider narrative
and then in november that whole theory
that toby could be playing uncle ben
is coming back uh people are buzzing
about that in november
but then something crazy happens our in
december 4th
sony latin america on youtube posts a
video that they quickly make private
and this video compiled scenes from sam
raimi's and mark webbs and john watts
respective spider-man films
and that video said quote who is your
favorite spider-man you don't have to
choose in the marvel multiverse
anything can happen in spider-man 3 you
will quite possibly see
everyone yes the three peter parkers
saving the world together
what does that mean who cut that
together why did it get uploaded who
knows
and do they still have a job
wow yeah that was a really i remember
when that came out and i was like oh
[ __ ] this is confirmed confirmed and
then it just disappeared which is very
it was suspect um so uh a couple days
later december 8th
another huge bombshell the hollywood
reporter reports that alfred molina is
returning as
dr auto octavius and spider-man 3
another big bombshell
and this is what happens pay attention
closely to what happens in today's
following
really on the same day colliders jeff
snyder claims that
jamie foxx andrew garfield and kirsten
dunst will all be returning and
reprising their roles
said toby mcguire is in talks to return
and that he expects
emma stone to reprise her role as gwen
stacy pregnancy permitting
he cites no sources but it doesn't
matter the story gets picked up
everywhere because collider is a good
one we like the lighter we can trust
collider
yes collider is pretty uh reliable
pretty reliable um
and then uh the next day december 9th
scooper charles murphy murphy's
multiverse a fairly reliable one
not not the worst one out there but i'm
doing a disservice by by grading any
scooper honestly
but he claims the next day that charlie
cox is joining the cast of spider-man 3
as well as matt murdock and or daredevil
and then
that same day the justjared.com twitter
account posts a paparazzi shot of tobey
mcguire in los
angeles at wardrobe workroom for a
costume fitting
and then thanks to all this frantic
casting news everyone just assumes that
it's going to be toby getting suited up
for spider-man 3.
yeah i mean like at that point once
again we were pretty much
jonesing for news like it was like that
period where like we just wanted well
yeah we all wanted it to be the case
like this is the reality we want and
when it's a reality you want it's so
easy to make it the reality
you believe is reality um exactly
wanda i mean
it's something we have to look at is uh
is the media cycle pattern here so
remember back in october when doctor
strange was reported
uh the same kind of thing is happening
here in december
a legitimate news report comes out and
then
within 48 hours scoopers see spider-man
3 trending
and then they just start posting all
these unconfirmed claims to cash in on
fan hopes
and they mix it all together as one big
story that trends more and more and more
and no one really knows what the truth
is at that point
because sony is not ready to market this
film
they don't want to leak anything about
the plot so they say nothing and then
that void of confirmation scoopers and
fan theories can
feast and grow and evolve but the more
that they say
nothing and like the more that like the
the hype for spider-man builds and like
it it just makes it much harder to find
the actual truth um because people are
just like spreading
just well like no i don't want to say
disinformation but like less than
accurate
right information for based on based on
facts that we don't fully have yet
information that can't be confirmed
either way right yes and yeah
um now uh shameless as we are on
december 9th new rockstars released a
theory video titled spider-man 3 doc awk
confirmed
to mcgraw andrew garfield and daredevil
2 question mark
and i feel like i'm you know i grew up
with jon stewart where i'll just say
like oh if you put a question mark at
the end of anything you're not saying
it's true yet you're just asking if it's
true but
exactly read it that way you know we're
not making any claims i mean you could
think we're making notes
but we're not despite toby mcguire
spider-man being in
a portal in the thumbnail if you watch
the video i do kind of lay out what we
know to be fast and i do my best to
separate what has been confirmed versus
what has been rumored or special always
watch the video always
watch it the whole way through yeah okay
but then uh december 14th
scooper the illuminati claims that
willem dafoe and thomas hayden church
are in the process of having deals
finalized to reprise their roles as
green goblins sam and spider-man 3.
and then december 24th christmas eve new
rockstars rogue theory season finale we
use a thumbnail with toby in a portal
again
uh and that was where i won theory of
the year for
a pitch that included toby and andrew
making a crossover but really it was
like
a much bigger theory that also involved
one division and loki
i think i of course brought in mephisto
in that theory
uh and multiverse of madness and i think
i ended with like doctor strange playing
chess with charles xavier
um but i don't i don't well
award oh i don't know i think all i got
was like
one of these or something
dang this should be the actual theory of
the year award that'd be great
but at least in this thumbnail we put
the ultimate theory on the thumbnail so
you know people the ultimate theory
let's be real
it is just a theory um okay so now we're
in the new year of 2021
january 15th comicbook.com claims that
charlie cox was indeed on the set for
spider-man 3 and has wrapped filming
they cite no
source really all they say is
comicbook.com has learned that the actor
was indeed on the separate marvel
studios movie
and then um really they just cite
charles murphy's past claim about cox to
try to make it more legitimate but then
oh things are getting real interesting
here
february 1st a doordash driver in
atlanta claims to have delivered food to
andrew garfield but then deletes the
posts but they continue to spread online
wow that's why the door dash scoopers
are here
all over it uh wow i didn't think door
dash would be involved but here we are
where's the uber intel let's get that
uber on it they are they're not part of
the network they don't know
[ __ ] yes uber eats drivers they don't
know
they're like which one's andrew garfield
like get out of here
um okay so then uh february 5th geeks
worldwide claims that according to an
unnamed source willem dafoe was reported
on set for spider-man 3 and will reprise
his role oh my god
it's confirmed um so now we enter into
our final
phase here where we get confirmations
and denials
so the first one was the denial on
february 9th where tom holland denied
that
tim mcguire or andrew garfield were in
spider-man 3. he told esquire another
legitimate obligation
uh he said no no they will not be
appearing in this film
unless they have hidden the most massive
piece of information from me which i
think is too big of a secret for them to
keep for me but as of yet
no it'll be a continuation of the
spider-man movies that we've been making
i mean it's tom holland it's tom holland
that's the thing we found we can't
always trust holland
uh and for many fans they can't trust
any actor
for good reason paul bettany freaking
toyed with fans about a big patio
coming in one division i'll never
forgive him for that
never forgive him i love you paul but
like god why why
why really the one who broke it was jj
abrams and benedict cumberbatch back for
star trek into darkness where people are
like so benecumber matches playing khan
right
and abrams is like no he's definitely
not playing khan lindelof i think co
wrote that movie was like
no he's not playing khan cover batch is
like no i'm not playing khan
movie comes out khan
why didn't you just say he's playing
khan why were you hiding that they
wanted it to be the big twist
like i feel like people would have
complained that they were retreading
territory so they were like that's not
god they broke it for the rest of
us um february 24th the title of
spider-man 3 is confirmed to be
spider-man no way home and they doing
this fun video that kind of shows all
the other titles they're speculating
like home worlds but that was crossed
out
and called boring which you could read
is a knock against multiverse theories
but empty fans are looking into the
shape of that border
around the title and they claim it looks
like the island of puerto rico
which they say is a miles morales clue
confirmed
[Music]
oh [ __ ] puerto rico confirmed
the cornerstone of the spider-verse is
puerto rico i think
i think only then did i start to get
worried about the fan base i was like oh
my god
what's happened to us how do we get here
hey man
puerto rico is uh it's very important to
the spider-man mythos oh yeah
then uh some interesting news comes out
i don't know if it's news but march 19th
william spencer who's andrew garfield's
longtime stunt double he posts
and then deletes pictures from his
instagram account showing him on a set
somewhere
supposedly with greg townley we don't
know if he's wait he tagged greg
townley on there and greg townley is tom
holland's stunt double
so why are they on a saturday or what
are they waiting
delete the pictures why are they deleted
[Music]
what's going on there what is going on
townley
uh now i should say throughout this
whole time there have been all kinds of
quote unquote leaks
on reddit and 4chan i'm only going to
single out one here this is from
redditor
you spidey forever 245 who claims
uh another toby andrew crossover plot
leak you can read it yourself
but the reason why this one i think is
worth bringing up is because this same
person predicted
julia louis dreyfus would be the episode
five cameo in falcon winter soldier
hours before the episode dropped how did
they know
who do they know a lot of people though
because of that see them as credible
but you know look into that person's
posting history you'll see that they
also posted leaks like hamila khan being
mepisto's daughter and then deleted it
so i don't know
wow uh what a stretch kamala khan being
with pistols not really
i've never i would have never even
thought of that so my wildest
imagination
you can make up your own mind on that
one but then interesting quote last
month
february 17th alfred molina told variety
that doc
ock died in the 2004 movie but that
quote in this universe no one really
dies
and then maybe spider-man 3 would pick
up with his character
from that moment in the river and that
they might be using de-aging technology
on his appearance
so this kind of sounds like maybe
they're kind of bridging the universes
together in a kind of multiverse right
yeah like when when that quote came out
i was like oh so like we're just
literally just doing like a spider-man
2.5 type of deal with this uh with this
movie and like continuing that story
with
with doc ock has gotten mixed opinions
because some people just wanted to die
and other people were just like yeah
let's give us more.cock
and the latest news as of this taping
may 4th 2021
uh andrew garfield went on josh
horowitz's the happy sad confused
podcast
joshua woods is great he always gets
like good quotes from people like ken
feige he like knows everyone
um and he confirmed or claimed that he
is not reprising his role as spider-man
and empty i think you and i should just
watch this clip and react to it i don't
know how to bring up the spider-man
stuff because obviously i don't even
want to like
ruin anything if there is something to
ruin except to service
anything to ruin bro i have to just
quickly just cut you off
there's nothing to ruin really like they
might be doing something
but then ain't none like i ain't
i ain't got a call like i feel like i'm
in a game of
werewolf or mafia where i'm like i'm not
the werewolf i promise you i am not the
werewolf and everyone's like you're the
werewolf
okay so for the record my friend on a
stack of whatever you have there the
unequivocal yes no answer
i did not get a call
and we do recommend you watch the whole
interview because josh horowitz is
is amazing he's i don't know how he gets
these answers out of people
so when this came out a lot of people a
lot of people we know a lot of people
respect immediately claimed that andrew
garfield must
be lying and i get it i get why they say
that because they're kind of doing what
everyone who plays werewolf or mafia
or resistance i love that game they all
do this they all start reading into the
deniers words through their body
language as if we're all liar experts
but really we're just going by our own
confirmation biases
of what we want to be true and in this
case we want andrew garfield to be lying
because we want him to be in this movie
i reject your reality and substitute my
own i can't even lie i was feeling the
same way while watching it i was just
like
are you really telling the truth andrew
because like i really want him
to be lying right like me too totally
right i feel the same way
um and like you know you look at a
statement like i haven't gotten a call
and then you claim oh well you know he
wouldn't get the call his agent would or
you know he said call but he didn't say
email or text you know like he's
speaking in code in this moment like
this is all scripted ahead of time
and he's just giving a great performance
i don't know i'm not a lion expert i
can't
tell i don't know andrew garfield that
well i don't i can't look at people's
people dilation be like oh they're
sweating more their heart rate's going
up
uh but i'll i will say that i don't
think andrew garfield would be
that candid in talking about it and
again i'm not
a lie expert i just think in my
experience celebrities tend to clam up
they'll say less from fear of losing
their jobs than have these long-winded
run-ons about werewolf
where you know if you bring up werewolf
and if you're lying you would never do
that because you know
as a werewolf player the more you talk
the more suspicion you bring on yourself
yeah if you're lying or maybe you could
be doing like a reverse reverse
psychology like right look at me
i'm just saying all this and like so you
guys think about i'm not lying but like
you never
know you never never know because andrew
garfield is a great actor he's got the
thing
these are actors it's so hard to figure
out if an actor is lying
right because this is what they do for a
living
i'll say as good as andrew garfield is
that
would be the best performance of his
life that would be fantastic
if that would be better than anything we
saw on social network anything in
hacksaw ridge
anything of those two spider-man movies
he
that would be pretty impressive for him
uh so but you're right it's impossible
to know so
we come to our final question are we
looking at cameos or caming
nose i'm sorry uh
well here's what we can confirm it seems
likely that the multiverse will be
involved
in this film at least likely you know
based on alfred molina's quote
uh based on doctor strange's involvement
in the plot like why do you bring in the
sorcerer's supreme if you're not gonna
go explore the multiverse or at least
the implications of multiverse
as of this taping we do not have
confirmation that that
means toby maguire andrew garfield or
charlie cox
will be in it we could have a totally
crazy multiverse story that just doesn't
include them
you know it's totally also very possible
i mean like the
spider-man 3 or spider-man no way home
rather could just very well just be
setting
up like a future spider-verse trilogy
right um in that like the
things that are happening right now
don't necessarily include
toby mcguire or andrew garfield right
and either way
we can't rule out the rumor either like
it could totally happen in spider-man no
way home
like uh but we also have to admit like
as you said even if the movie comes out
and these guys are not in it in fans
minds it totally could have happened
right and it was taken away from them
and that's the tricky thing with this
rumor because
you know empty has said this we want
these to be true again we want a
live-action spider-verse that brings
back
everybody toby andrew willem charlie cox
everybody we want it but for now it
remains what we have always said it is
here at new rockstars it's a theory
and all these claims out there that are
being used as evidence for it being a
fact
they do not constitute news my friends
and by sharing them all
as a fact you are perpetuating
a broken new system that only exists
that thrives by manipulating you they
need you to just like
knee jerk share something and then think
about it later
and the time you've already shared it
doesn't matter it's out there more
people are going to see it
my fear with no way home is that if it's
the case that
none of these rumored cameos happen some
of these fans
will turn on the movie as if it betrayed
them as if it broke oh that's 100
going to happen in that scenario yeah
and i don't there's no way
yeah like people's expectations are way
too high right people are setting
themselves up for disappointment well
but my
the deeper fear i have is that some of
these fans will find
a villain and that villain will be
someone like john watts or kevin feige
or likely amy pascal or aviarad or like
zendaya or something like that
and then scoopers out there will claim
more unnamed sources that insist
insist that toby and andrew were gonna
be in this film
until whoever that villain was shot it
down
so go tweet at that person for the
answers and then
all these tweets will come out and then
one particular account will like a lot
of these tweets
and post certain things and then take it
down and then everyone will be like wait
a minute
is that account andrew garfield's
throwaway account that he's been using
to stalk all these theories
and then that account we'll never know
but they'll start just dropping
these cryptic things like q these q
drops and eventually we'll all see a
freaking hashtag that says release the
toby and andrew cut
release the toby and andrew cut and then
i'll be on our literally
looked into the future because that's
that's probably gonna happen no matter
what happens with this movie that's
gonna happen
100 i don't know why people we keep
doing this but it's just humanity
it's human nature in the digital age but
we beg of you
take it from guys whose theories are
debunked 90
of the time at least just you can dream
big
dream as big as you want with your fan
theories share them around go crazy
but keep an open mind and let the
evidence guide you
and whatever the story is when it comes
to you just be grateful for whatever
comes
and then you'll be fine yes exactly
emphasis on the grateful
the mcu could have never happened all of
this amazing stuff
with the mcu with with with sony and
marvel could have never happened yeah so
like the fact that we're getting these
amazing stories
is a is just incredible so let's be just
be happy
well thank you for that amazing
breakdown of the whole
spider-man situation it's a whole it's a
mess but what isn't a mess
is our amazing box of scraps
and today's box of scraps question of
the day is what
totally harmless conspiracy theory do
you kind of believe in eric
okay uh let's see um
uh conspiracy theories used to be so
much more fun
in the 90s you know until the harm
yeah yep and then the internet ruined
them
um i love the conspiracy theories that
like loki's digging into the whole db
cooper one
the uh polybius game one those are fun
um for a while i was uh i was what's it
called
the moon conspiracy theorists you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh okay i i know it's silly
and dumb and um you know people will be
annoyed by it but i
i kind of believe the fake melania
theory
it's so you know what i'm with you bro
and it's probably not true but i've seen
some of those pictures and i'm like
hmm yo sometimes it's mad
suspect i'm like yo who is this yeah and
so many
others so many secrets and lies have
been confirmed from that
from that group of people right like
it's it's totally
true it's so much of it so it's like i
wouldn't put it past
him because we know it's clear melania
hates being in that marriage right like
she did not want him to be president she
renegotiated her prenup before she moved
into the white house
that was actually true so it's like yeah
i wouldn't be surprised i just think
it's so silly
it feels like the the fake saddam
hussein doubles that they had
you know it's just such a goofy like it
would be
funny yeah you know it's just like oh my
god
yeah no i totally sort of yeah i believe
in that sort of too
i think one of my friends at one point
tweeted that she wanted to do a short
film or a web series about all the fake
melania's who had to live together
like oh
just like a desperate housewives kind of
thing or oh my god
yo you're giving these people way too
many i keep saying desperate housewives
i mean like a real housewives kind of
thing like they're all throwing wine at
each other and
they're fake housewives of trump the
real housewives of uh
of 1600 pennsylvania
anyway it's a conspiracy theory i'm not
saying that's the truth i just think
it's so silly it's
very fun yeah
i i like that one i have a weird one
that i don't i don't think it's like a
major conspiracy this is just a me thing
i um i dread jerry duty so much
that i literally refuse to say the words
jury duty
around my phone oh no because i feel
it's
totally nonsensical i hope your phone's
in another room empty because my phone
is right here
oh no like i'm scared to say it because
i'm afraid to get jury duty
and i've said it like 17 times around my
phone so if i get jury duty i'm
literally going to tell you guys
immediately
because that it's true um but no it's
it's a totally
baseless your voice is now beaming
across
um maybe 40 000 we think people who are
watching at this point oh god
uh so if they're all listening off their
headphones they're all going to get
your phones pinged to get you jersey
exactly i've given you all jury duty i'm
so sorry
that's the worst 40 000 jury duties
i oh yes i'm totally getting jury duty
now i've said it like a zillion times
oh my god but yeah that's my weird thing
it's not that weird and see our phones
are listening to us at all times
yeah it's very true that is very clear
but that is it for us on today's
big question i want to thank eric for
joining me and giving us all those
amazing spider facts
you can follow him at ea voss where he
posts all
amazing stuff and like all that good
stuff that you need to know so please
follow him at eavos follow me at
mastertainment but most importantly
follow new rockstars wherever you can
find us especially on youtube
and when you do on youtube make sure to
hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications
every time we upload a video because we
always be uploading some dope [ __ ]
anyways have a good day everybody good
day everyone
see ya bye
[Music]
you